i just want to make sure that i have
this right um
giannio is not a taiwanese monk but
rather someone named
jason mendoza a failed dj from
jacksonville florida i wasn't a failed
dj i was pretty successful what did you
do for a living i was an amateur dj
specializing in edm
electronic dance music i was also an
avenger hip-hop backup dancer and
amateur body spray inventor um i did
pranks on vine none of those are jobs
what did you do to make money oh i sold
fake drugs to college kids see in hell
you know what i just realized i always
say that when leaving a room but right
now
it's accurate
i will literally
see all of you in hell not if i see you
first
i've never marvelized a janet before
jacksonville style baby 2000 points
thanks jason
cannon
door
oh
i see jason mendoza's here jason might
not be the smartest guy in the world but
he is
the dumbest guy in the world
oh jason buddy all you had to do was to
keep quiet but you couldn't stop talking
about kendall jenner or that dumb
quarterback what was his name derek
bortles always ranting about derek
bortles lucky for you my friend jaguar's
games are the only ones televised in the
bad place because i suck
no they don't all we need is a defense
and an offense and some rule changes
tahani said that you helped michael by
putting your hand on his chest and doing
some sort of healing magic yeah a nurse
did that to calm me down once when i
crashed my jet ski into a manatee
we have jason who can
what are jalapeno poppers
oh i know this one okay they're
deep-fried jalapenos filled with cheese
one time at a buffalo wild wings in
jacksonville the the nice one not the
one above the gas station i ate 50 of
them in two minutes
everyone at the hospital was so
impressed no jenna come back hi there go
sure thing no stop doing that me go
goodbye jenna come back i love you i
love you too
please don't rap me out
don't worry i won't
because i'm not supposed to be here
either i don't know how i got here i
have no idea what's going on and i am
freaking out homie you gotta help me
i'm scared i hate to be the bearer of
bad news uh
i think you mean bad news bear
hi jason i love you
oh word
word i mean what is this no time to
explain
also i kind of forgot you gotta leave
pillboi alone from now on
i'm trying to save them oh dip you got
religious inches
amen
amen i'm losing by three meditating to
calm myself down
i'd be winning by like a million if i
could play as the jags instead of
playing against the jags i hate scoring
against my own favorite team
but you already knew that
because this is the test yeah that's not
a revelation or something i explained
that very clearly
oh chidi sorry i got a joke for you bud
uh knock knock who's there you died
alone because you couldn't commit to
anyone
that alone because you couldn't commit
to anyone who no jason mendoza
[Applause]
janet my digital queen janet we can dare
to dream send nude pics of your heart to
me
jacksonville jaguars rule
oh dip you're back
jason yeah
what
but how
why
funny story remember how i made you
something and i thought i lost it
because it wasn't in my pocket turns out
it was in my other pocket by the time i
found it you were gone i was just gonna
leave it for you but i was worried it
would get eaten by that magic squirrel
so i decided to wait for you to come
back
every so often a different janet came
but
i knew it wasn't you jason it's been
like a thousand beramies i know
but i wanted to see you again
it was actually pretty easy to wait
i sort of just sat quietly and let my
mind drift away
thought about you
and the infinity of the universe
kind of like a monk
what do you mean there's so much
thoughts on my brain it's like my head
is filled with rocks
heaven is so racist you're so smart
every day you teach me something new
about art and history and and why i
shouldn't eat everything that smells
good because
sometimes it's candles
you're basically like a hot genius
teacher who sometimes has sex with me
you're a student
that used to happen a lot at leonard
skinner high school but this time you
won't be arrested
oh i love you
tahani before we start i know you were a
buddhist monk and kept a vow of silence
would you prefer to remain silent here
as well
when i say i'm meditating i'm just
trying to figure out what the fork is
happening i think we might be in an
alien zoo or on a prank show no jean you
were dead whoa that's a dope prank
got to give it up yeah okay it's a
torture museum famous examples of bad
behavior and explanations of the torture
they earned is there a gift y'all jason
this is hell of course it's a gift shop
first white person to grow dreadlocks
and first person to call ultimate
frisbee ultimate
you